I love you too I usually say I know why
you're happy I don't know why you're
happy I know why I'm happy because Kim's
young undeb North Korea
yesterday told South Korea that he's
willing to meet with the leader of the
United States
but Putin wasn't available so Trump's Co
Trump is going fat man and little boy
we're gonna have a day that looks like
Trump is gonna travel to North Korea in
May and of course there are reason is a
hundred reasons why this is dangerous
we're talking about after all a family
that has reneged on every deal they ever
signed and Kim jong-un can't be trusted
either
[Applause]
that's watching all the cable news last
night into all these liberals who are
reflexively hating on this a Obama
remember him proposed the exact same
thing in 2008 and they loved it and be
you know [ __ ] you you don't live on the
west coast where a new can get here
faster than an uber from North Korea
what is this [ __ ] no president has
ever done this yeah and they all failed
so I'm gonna file this one under so
crazy it just might work this could be
the one thing that Trump honestly is
uniquely qualified to pull off because
Kim and him Rocketman and Rain Man are
mirror image is in a weird way they
respect and like each other you know
Trump said he's a smart cookie they have
the same interests flattery celebrity
tyranny they both have daddy issues and
overeating issues and problematic family
members and inexplicable hair
[Applause]
they both love missile parades and they
both lie on their golf scores and one
day you see staff members working for
them and the next day they disappear who
is the one American that Kim likes
Dennis Rodman well Trump is the closest
thing we're gonna get to president
Dennis Rodman another stupid argument I
heard on TV last night well we'll just
be giving Kim the respect he and his
family have always craved so what so
what if it works
my old pot dealer used to hang out with
me cuz I'm a celebrity I still got free
weed and you know what if you hate Trump
so much I do this man I do be happening
because of Donald Trump it could be his
tough talk it could be because of the
sanctions could have been because of the
Olympics who knows what is in Kim Jong
Un's mind it could be because shape of
water won best picture and he saw that
and thought well if you can [ __ ] a fish
you can negotiate with a whale
but hey North Korea is not the only
place Trump will be traveling to next
week he's coming here to California
isn't that great he didn't want to but
this is where the porn stars are oh
you've been following that we now have a
full-on sex scandal in the White House
stormy Daniels is now suing him that was
the development this week on Monday she
filed a lawsuit now if you forgot who
she is stormy Daniels if you recall okay
the man who got 80% of the event
Jellicle vote for president 2016 and the
star of toxic [ __ ] load six met at the at
a golf tournament in 2006 after which
she was paid to shut up about it but
Sara Huckabee Sanders this week really
[ __ ] up and she said in the press
briefing that Trump won an arbitration
case with her a lie that contradicted
her original lie that Trump had nothing
to do with stormy Daniel so now it's
just a he-said she-said storm he says
they had an affair and Trump says they
didn't but who you gonna believe the
fake blonde with big tits or stormy
Daniels
I couldn't wait to do that when I must
say but here's the big story dad just
not suing for money she is suing for the
right to talk about the fat disgusting
Trump sex that she had she wants to get
out of the non-disclosure agreement she
signed and Trump's lawyers this week
said they want to issue a gag order and
she said that cost extra but here's why
here's why she has a case because in the
settlement papers first of all in the
settlement papers Trump goes by an alias
and Elias David Dennison David Dennison
cuz Dirk Diggler was too on the nose
but those set up the settlement might be
invalid because Trump
I mean Dirk Diggler forgot to sign it
this happens a lot to a stable genius
but you know trumpet he's always going
on about other countries are Latin again
it's oh now really not even because the
president [ __ ] porn stars but because
she has a better lawyer
Donald Trump managed to find the one
woman in America to have sex with him
who then wanted to talk about it usually
when he has sex with someone he says
don't tell anyone and they're like not a
problem
but the best part is that the documents
say that's this Jeremy Daniels has quote
certain still images which to me sounds
like dick pics right what what else can
still images that he doesn't want out
there and you can tell it's Trump's dick
in the picture because well two reasons
first is a big sign on top of it Trump
penis
and also it's in Sean Hannity's mouth